para mí significa
varias cosas porque para mí para la
comunidad de musulmanes aquí en
norteamérica significa un día donde hubo
una perdida porque nosotros también
somos norteamericanos nos sentimos
americanos y en ese sentido
nos tocó los afectos murieron decenas y
decenas de musulmanes más de 80
musulmanes en septiembre 11
musulmanes de nuestras comunidades
fueron rescatistas los días o septiembre
11 y así por el estilo
nuestra comunidad tiene entonces otro
obtuvo otra repercusión además de sufrir
el ataque como un ataque en el que
nosotros mismos fuimos víctimas también
fue la singular y singular
singularización de los musulmanes en
norteamérica como par como que si
tuviesen algún tipo de responsabilidad o
solidaridad con ese tipo de actos y
también
desde ese entonces la islamofobia
comenzó a
afianzarse
lamentablemente afectó a nuestros niños
en las escuelas a nuestros
personas en los trabajadores en sus
lugares de trabajo a toda la comunidad
cuando viajas ya no es
niños que aparecen en listas para no
viajar de apenas 34 años de listas de
sospechosos con sospechosos de que
verdad pero así por el estilo esto
pasado 20 años desde septiembre 11
han sido toda una especie de
transformación para nuestra comunidad de
desert singularizada estar aislada hacer
una comunidad mucho más abierta mucho
más
ávida de participar cívicamente en todos
los aspectos sociales políticos y
económicos de las de la sociedad en los
eeuu